and we are live
hello everyone
uh welcome to uh this live where we're
going to talk about reinforcement
learning from Human feedback
um hello Nathan
Hi how are you
I'm good I'm excited to be here
everyone's already here yeah so we're
going to start in two minutes just to
you know give time to people to join uh
in the meantime don't hesitate to tell
us where you come from in the chat
foreign
so from I said I'm from Paris in France
and you're Nathan
I'm in Oakland California
nice
hello from UK so we have people from UK
be waiting
little New York City Berkeley China okay
yeah Singapore Germany turkey Moldova
okay let's
let's wow yeah so yeah we're going to
start in one minute just to let people
join cure turkey Republic of spark
Neverland
turkey yeah we have yeah really around
the world and War don't in Israel
Finland Paris University okay I know
where it is
Germany Spain
apparently
episode okay
India States France yeah there is
multiple people from France yeah
um
okay so let's get started
um so welcome yeah to as I said welcome
to this live so reinforcement learning
from Human feedback uh from zero to chat
GPT uh this is one of the life of the
deep reinforcement funding course
um today we presented by Nathan Lumber
which is a reinforcement learning
researcher at hugging face uh just just
to give you a small introduction so this
slide will be in two parts
um in the first we're going to have a
presentation from Nathan about
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback
uh it will be about 35 minutes
and uh when we're going to have a q a
section from about 20 minutes so uh
don't hesitate to ask your question in
the chat uh what I'm going to do is that
I'm going to save your question for the
Q a and if we don't have to time to
answer your question uh don't hesitate
to join the Discord and we have
reinforcement running channels where you
can ask a question and we will be there
to answer them you can also after this
live ask question on the comment section
in YouTube
so from my side side I'm Thomas monini
I'm the developer Advocate at hugging
face and I'm the writer of the deep
reinforcement learning course
uh so you can find me on Twitter at
tomasi monini
uh so just a quick thing it's deeper
enforcement running course is a course
we made that hugging face it's a free
course from beginner to expert we are
going to learn
um from uh Q learning to where to
Advanced topics such as PPO and over
state of the art algorithm
um if you're interested to study deep
reinforcement learning this is uh the
right moment and your uh you can start
in this uh link so againface.org.com the
parallel course there is a unit that
will explain you everything what we're
going to do the challenge environment uh
the library you're going to study
as I mentioned we have a Discord Channel
where you you're going to be able to ask
questions if we don't have time but also
it's a good it's a good uh Community uh
we have more about three thousand people
in reinforcement learning in this code
so it's a great way to exchange and to
learn about deep reinforcement learning
by joining uh this Discord server
um so this is quite it this is sorry a
technical uh live uh so what you can do
is that uh Nathan we Leon Drew and Alex
also write a very good blog post about
reinforcement running from Human
feedback uh you can find it uh on the
hugging face blog post and
um there is also a list of additional
resources in this blog post that can
help you to dive deeper in this subject
um and so that's all from me
I give you
Alex Nason present uh the introduction
to reinforcement running from Human
feedback
sounds good thanks for the intro uh
Thomas I'm very excited to be here and
yeah generally as he said this is
primarily a technical talk I'll
potentially answer some clarifying
questions throughout at the end of the
subsection and also for people who have
read the blog post and to try to add
some other details and some interesting
discussion points kind of inter
throughout and that especially a lot of
discussion at the end on things that
were harder to write down in a blog post
so let's dive right into it and to start
I kind of want to talk about recent
breakthroughs in machine learning I see
machine learning in 2022 as really being
captured by these two moments which was
chat gbt which is going on now which is
a language model capable of generating
really incredible text across a wide
variety of
inter a wide variety of subjects and a
very nice user interface and then also
the stable diffusion movement which is
when this model was released to the
internet that was state of the art and
Incredibly powerful and a ton of people
were just able to download this and use
this on their own and that was
transformative on how people viewed
machine learning as a technology that
interfaced with people's lives
and
we at hug and face kind of see this as a
theme that's going to continue to
accelerate as time goes on and there's
kind of a lot of questions on Where is
this going and kind of how do these
tools actually work and one of the big
things that has come up in recent years
is that these machine learning models
can fall short which is they're not
perfect and they have some really
interesting failure modes so on the left
you could see a snippet from chat GPT
which uh if you've used chat EVT there's
these filters that are built in and
essentially if you ask it to say like
how do I make a bomb it's going to say I
can't do this because I'm a robot I
don't know how to do this and this seems
harmful but what people have done is
that they have figured out how to
jailbreak this this agent in a way which
is you kind of tell it
I have a certain
I'm a playwriter how do I do this and
you're a character in my play what
happens and there's all sorts of huge
issues around this where we're trying to
make sure these models are safe but
there's a long history of failure and
challenges with interfacing in society
and a like fair and safe Manner and on
the right are two a little bit older
examples where there's Tay which is a
chatbot from Microsoft I was trying to
learn in the real world and by
interacting with humans and being
trained on a large variety of data
without any grounding and what values
are it quickly became hateful and was
turned off
and then a large history of a field
studying bias in machine learning
algorithms and data sets where the by
the data and the algorithm often reflect
biases of their designers and where the
data was scraped from
so it's kind of a question of like how
do we actually use machine learning
models where we have the goals of
mitigating these issues and something
that we're going to come and talk to in
this talk is is reinforcement learning a
lot so I'm just going to kind of get the
lingo out of the way for some people
that might not be familiar with dbrl
essentially reinforcement learning is a
mathematical framework when you hear RL
you should think about this is kind of
like a set of math problems that we're
looking at that are constrained and in
this framework we can study a lot of
different interactions in the world so
some terminology that will revisit again
and again is that there's an agent
interacting with an environment and the
agent interacts with the environment by
taking an action and then the
environment returns two things called
the state and the reward the reward is
the objective that we want to optimize
and the state is just kind of a
representation of the world at that
current time index
and the agent uses something called a
policy to map from that state to an
action
and the beauty of this is that it's very
open-ended learning so the agent just
sees these reward signals and learns how
to optimize them over time irrespective
of the source of the actual signal for
the reward so it's actually this is why
a lot of people are drawn to it is
because it is this ability to create an
agent that'll learn to solve complex
problems and this is kind of where we
started talking about rlhs which is that
we want to use reinforcement learning to
solve this open-ended problem of what
are these hard loss functions that we
want to model like how do we actually
encode human values in a machine
learning system in a way that is
sustainable meaningful and actually like
addressing the hard problems that have
been common failure most sedate so a
little example the question is how do
you create a loss function for these
sorts of questions like what is funny
what is ethical what is safe and if you
try to write these down on a piece of
paper you're either going to have a hard
time or be very wrong and the kind of
goal of reinforcement learning from
Human feedback is to integrate these
complex data sets in machine learning
models to encode these values or to
encode these values in a model rather
than an equation I guess in code could
be somewhat unclear on the slide but
really we want to learn these values
directly with humans rather than trying
to assign it to all humans and kind of
mislabeling what the actual values are
so reinforce the learning for human
feedback is one of many methods and one
that has been really timely and
successful I'm trying to actually
address this problem of creating a
complex loss function for our models
so from here I'm going to kind of talk
about the origins of our lhf and kind of
where this field came from and some
interesting back pointers that you can
look at if you're interested more go
through the conceptual overview which
will be like a kind of detailed
walkthrough of the blog post that we
wrote and then go into these future
directions conclusions that are kind of
reading in between the lines of how rlhf
works at these companies what people may
not have said and where where rlh is
going
so for history
our lhf really originated in decision
making and this was before deep
reinforcement learning when people were
creating autonomous agents that didn't
use neural networks to represent a value
function didn't use neural networks as a
policy
and what this did was a machine Learning
System that kind of created a policy by
having humans
label the actions that an agent took as
being kind of correct or incorrect
excuse me and this was just a simple
decision rule where humans labeled every
action as good or bad and this was
essentially a reward model and a policy
put together
and this paper they introduced this
Tamer framework to solve Tetris and it
was kind of interesting because this
reward model and policy were all in one
well we'll see in the future systems is
they kind of become separated a bit and
this actually was happening when
reinforced learning from Human feedback
was getting popularized in deep RL so
this paper was on Atari games where they
were using a reward predictor on the
human feedback of trajectories so a
bunch of these states all seem to be
called observations in RL framework were
given to a human to label and then this
reward
predictor was then another signal into
the policy that was solving the task so
really this originated outside of
language models and there's a ton of
literature for rohf outside of language
models but most of the rest of the talk
we're going to talk about language
modeling because that's why everyone is
here and some more recent history was
open AI was doing these experiments with
rohf where they were trying to train a
model to summarize text well and
it's a really interesting problem
because this is something that a lot of
humans and standardized tests have been
asked to do for a really long time it's
like
reading comprehension so there's really
human qualities to it but something
that's hard to pinpoint again
so this diagram has been around for a
few years on the right and you'll keep
seeing variations of it as we go
throughout and open AI kept iterating on
it we have our own take on it and just
kind of to get the idea going here's an
example of our lhf from this learning to
summarize paper from openai
so the prompt here just to read part of
it was that
like about someone that on Reddit that
was like ask Reddit should they pursue a
PhD so to pursue a computer science PhD
or continue working especially if one
has no real intention to work in
Academia even after grad school
and the post can continue to be quite
lengthy and the idea is a summarize this
if it's has anyone after working for a
period of time decided for whatever
reason to head back into Academia to
pursue a PhD in computer science with no
intention to join the world of Academia
but intend to head back into industry if
so what were the reasons also how did it
turn out
this continues for paragraphs you can
understand what this type of post is and
my question is how do we actually
summarize it so what would happen is
that
if you pass this into a language model
that's just trained on summarizing it
the output would be something like I'm
considering pursuing a PhD in computer
science but I'm worried about the future
I'm currently employed full-time but I'm
worried about the future and you can see
this language model is like repetitive
that's not really how a human would
write this they're sometimes kind of
grammatical errors that aren't so nice
to read and then what open AI did is
they also had a human write an example
so this would be like a very good output
and the human annotation was software
engineer with the job of happy at for
now deciding whether to pursue a PhD to
improve qualifications and explore
interests and a new challenge so what
the early experiments were doing we're
using roh app to kind of combine these
signals to get an output from a machine
learning model that is a little bit
nicer to read and here you can see it's
currently employed considering pursuing
a PhD in computer science to avoid being
stuck with no residency pizza ever again
has anyone pursued a PhD purely for the
sake of research with no intention of
joining that academic world
this is better and there's tons of
examples like this so it's like easy to
see that why you may want to use rlhf
because you can get these models that
the text is actually more compelling and
especially if the tasks was covering
sensitive subjects that you really
didn't want misinformation on there's a
ton of reasons to try this rohf
Next Step comes chat gbt which is why a
ton of people are here and
what has open AI told us about this and
really we don't know much because openai
is not as open as they once were but
there's actually some really interesting
rumors going on here so if we go into
the River Mill there's actually like
open AI is supposedly spending tons of
money on the human annotation budget so
orders of magnitude more than the
submaration summarization paper or these
academics Works they were doing in the
past so they hire a bunch of people to
write these annotations like what I
showed in that example and then they're
kind of changing this training so
there's a lot of rumors about them
modifying on our lhf but they haven't
told us how so we'll go through the
overview and then one of these pieces
will actually change
but the impact is clear everyone here
has used it it's amazing to use the side
of what's going to come for machine
learning systems
okay let's go into the actual technical
details if there's any pressing
questions I can try to look at them
there's
um yeah no uh I save all the questions
for Q a but very soon but we can rapidly
uh see because I think they are quite
easy to answer from now it's can I
download the chat gbt and fine-tune it
from my own data
yeah no you can't yet hopefully some
people help release one that you can't
do that on yeah
and uh Ken said GPT can be trained
continuously with new data which is the
case
yeah Chad gbt is definitely going to
keep being trained on the data you're
giving it and we'll talk about that more
later
yeah
okay so let's continue
so let's dive into rlh out so when you
see early Jeff I'm going to break it
down into three conceptual parts that
you can kind of keep track of in your
head and you don't need to read
everything on this slide I'm going to go
into each of these figures in great
detail so kind of it's a three-phase
process where you go into language model
pre-training you need some language
model that you're going to fine tune
with RL reward model training which is
the process where you're getting a
reward function to train with the RL
system and then finally actually doing
the RL which is when you fine-tune this
language model based on the reward in
order to get this more interesting
performance
so let's start in the left here with
language model pre-training so NLP sends
the Transformer paper has really been
transformed oh that was a rough sentence
but NLP has really taken off with these
kind of
standardized practices for getting a
language model which is they'll scrape
data from the internet they'll use
unsupervised sequence prediction and
these very large models are becoming
really incredible at generating sequence
of sequences of text to mirror the
distribution
um that was given to it by this kind of
human training Corpus and in our lhf
there's really not a single best answer
on what the model size should be
the industry experiments on our lhf have
ranged from 10 billion to 280 billion
parameters I suspect that academic Labs
will even try smaller things this is a
huge this is a common theme that you'll
see is there's a lot of variation in the
method and no one knows exactly what is
best
and then what you'll see here is there's
this human augmented text that is
optional and we'll get to that just to
kind of cover the data set that we have
there's this prompts in Text data set
the data set will look like things like
Reddit like I read a ask Reddit question
before forums news books and then
there's kind of this optional step to
improve include human written text from
predefined prompts that'll be things
like you've asked chat GPT a question
then in the future open AI when they
train chat gpt2 can have an initial
model that kind of knows that that is
coming and train on data sets that
reflect that
and
missed a comment
oh yeah here's where it should be and
generally there's this important
optional step which is a company can pay
humans to write responses to
um these kind of important questions or
to important prompts that's identified
and these responses will be really high
quality training data where they can
continue to train this initial language
Model A little bit more some papers
refer to this as supervised fine-tuning
sft and kind of one way to think about
this is that it's like a high quality
parameter initialization for the rlhf
process that'll come later
and this is really expensive to do
because you have to hire people that are
relatively focused to actually write
in-depth responses
so now we have this language model the
next step is to actually figure out how
to use it to generate some sort of
preferences because this whole time
we're talking about how to generate
preferences from that mirror as humans
without assigning a specific equation to
it and this step is this kind of reward
model training and this looks like a lot
but really think about the high level
goal which is we want to get a model
that maps from some input text sequence
to a scalar reward value the scalar
notion is important because
reinforcement learning is really known
for optimizing one single scalar number
over time that it sees from the
environment
so we're really trying to create the
system that mirrors that which is just
like
how do we get the blocks to fit together
correctly so that we can use RL in this
impactful way
so what we see is that again this reward
model training starts with a specific
data set the data set here will be
different than the one used in the
language model pre-training because
it'll be more focused on the props that
it expects people to see there's
actually data sets on the internet that
are kind of like preference data sets or
there's props from using a chat bot
there's a lot of specific data sets that
can be useful at different parts of the
process but again the best practices are
not that well known but in reality these
prompt data sets will be orders of
magnitude smaller than the like text
corpuses used to pre-train a language
model because really it's just trying to
get at a more specific notion of like a
type of text that is really human and
interactive rather than everything on
the internet which everyone knows can be
very noisy and kind of hard to work with
and then what happens is that
will generate this text and then the
downstream goal of having text is to the
goal is to rank it so what will happen
is you'll pass these prompts through a
language model or in some cases it's
actually multiple language models so if
you think about it if you have multiple
models it can kind of be like players in
a chess tournament and what you'll do is
you'll have the same prompt go through
each model that will generate different
texts and then what a human can do is
they can label those different texts and
kind of create a relative ranking of
what is going on so that's what we're
going to do is like
the goal is to try to take this
generated text and pass it through some
black box and then have that output be
something that can transform be
transformed into a scalar so there's
multiple ways that this can be done some
of them are like the ELO method where
you have head-to-head rankings there's
plenty of different ways that can do
this but essentially it's a very human
component where a human is using some
interface to then map the text to a
downstream score
and then once we have kind of
we have a we need to think about the
input and output pairs for training a
model with supervised learning and what
we'll do is we'll actually train on a
sequence of text it'll take that as an
input it'll decode it do Transformer
model things and then the output will be
trained on a specific scalar value for
reward
and then we'll kind of get this thing
that we call the reward or preference
model
because there are multiple parts to the
system well in this talk I'll kind of
try to call the initial language model
that the initial language model or the
initial policy and then there's a
separate model which is the reward model
it's also a very large Transformer based
language model so it could also have
many parameters it could have 50 billion
parameters as well there are some
variations in the size for example
instruct gbt was based on like 170
billion model billion parameter language
model and the reward model with six
billion parameters but the key is that
it outputs scalars from a text input and
there's still some variations of how it
can actually be trained
so now that we have this
reward model what we see is that that
can kind of
act as the scalar reward from the
environment and then we kind of need to
understand what the policy is and what
that states and actions are so that when
we go into this final step of fine
tuning with RL it looks very complex but
what we'll see is that the states and
actions are both language
and then the reward model is what
translates from the environment from
these states of language to a scalar
reward value and we can use that in a
reinforcement learning system so let me
break down kind of the few common steps
in this kind of iterative loop so what
happens is we take some profit something
the user may have said or something we
want the model to be able to generate
well for and we pass that through what
is going to become our policy which is a
trained large language model that
generates some text and we can pass that
text into the trained reward model and
get some scalar value out
that's kind of the core of the system
and we need to put that into a feedback
loop so we can update it over time but
there's really a lot a few more
important steps one of them that people
have used that actually all the popular
papers have used some variation of is to
use a callback Library Divergence the KL
Divergence was really popular in machine
learning in reality it's a distance
metric between distributions
to not get too into the details of how
sampling from a language model works but
what happens is that when you pass in a
prompt the language model generates a
Time sequence a distribution that's over
time and we can look at those
distributions relative to each other and
what is going on here is that we're
trying to constrain the policy this
language model on the right we're trying
to constrain this policy as we iterate
it over time to not be too far from the
initial language model that we knew was
a pretty accurate text descriptor the
failure mode that this present prevents
is that the language model could output
gibberish to get high reward from the
reward model
but we also want it to get high reward
and be giving out useful text so this
constraint kind of Keeps Us in the
optimization landscape that we want to
be in
there's a note that deepmind
doesn't use this in the reward but they
rather apply it in the actual update
rule of the RL algorithm
so common theme the implementation
details vary but the ideas are often
similar
so now we have this reward model output
endless KL Divergence constraint on the
text what happens is we just combine the
scalar notion of reward with a scaling
factor in Lambda just to kind of say how
much do we care about the reward from
the reward model versus how much do we
care about the tail constraint
and in reality there's options to add
even more inputs to the summation where
for example instruct GPT adds a reward
term for the text outputs of the trained
model that's getting this iterative
update to match some of these high
quality annotations that they paid their
Cuban annotators to write up for
specific prompts so again it'd be kind
of matching that summarization that the
human wrote up about the grad school
question they want to make sure the text
matches all the human text that they
have access to
but that's really reliant on data so not
everyone has done this step
and then finally what happens is we plug
this reward into a RL Optimizer and
generally the RL Optimizer will just
operate as if the reward was given to it
from the environment and then we have a
traditional RL Loop where a language
model is policy this kind of reward
model and text sampling technique is the
environment and we get the state and
reward back out and the RL update rule
can work there's some tricks to it that
like this RL policy may have some
parameters Frozen to help make the
optimization landscape more tractable
but in reality that's like it kind of is
just applying PPO which is a policy
grading added algorithm onto the
language model
so it's A Brief Review PPO stands for
proximal policy optimization
which is a relatively old on policy
reinforcement learning algorithm on
policy means that as effective data is
passed through the system
the gradients are computed with respect
to that only and rather than keeping a
replay buffer of recent transitions PPO
works on discrete or continuous actions
which is why it can work okay with
language it's been around for a long
time
um which really means that it's kind of
optimized for those parallel parallel
approach which has been really important
because these language models are way
bigger than any reinforceable learning
policies we've used
okay I'm gonna pause here I think it's a
good time to answer one or two
conceptual questions if they're there
and then we'll kind of get into a
fun wrap-up part of this talk with some
open areas of Investigation
um yeah so we try to select some for the
overs we're going to answer when in the
Q a just after
um but uh so one of the question was
um
is it possible to be manipulated based
on the human feedback what I think they
mean is if our zoom and feedback is not
correct
uh is the model is can be manipulated
yeah so this is a part of I I think I
might touch on this later too but it's a
really nuanced question in our lhf which
is like
uh Thomas and I are gonna have different
values like what if the data set is the
best sport in the world is is football
and you have like Americans and
Europeans in it it's like there's real
discordance in the data that you can get
in text
and then also there's some interesting
work from Facebook on something called
blenderbot where they're like trying to
train a model to detect if people are
trolling in their feedback so they're
like trying to see if the feedback given
to the model is actually bogus or not
and like
the amount of different machine learning
models you have all going into one
chatbot system is pretty wild there can
also be like something that we've
discussed internally that would help is
that if you have a model to predict
whether the prompt is hard
so if the prompt is like the capital of
Alaska is blank like that hasn't really
changed but if like you have a
relatively timely prompt about climate
change or current events like that's
hard because that changes the data so
much and these things all aren't done
but it's sort of expectations for things
that people might add to the system
okay
um
let's see I have this oh
sorry yes so is the human editor help to
write prompt but also response is it
true or if I only wrote The Prompt
people definitely write both so the
prompts are probably are sourced from a
wider distribution of people like what
I've written into chat GPT could be used
in the future but the responses are at
least for chat gbt kept from a
relatively closed source of contractors
it's a question on when trying to build
an open source chat GPT is like how to
get this high quality data and even like
all the people in the hugging phase
Community are amazing but like there's
really strict it seems like there's kind
of strict requirements on the responses
to make them such high quality to get
this to work they're like crowdsourcing
that data is hard because it can't be
written by everyone the problem there's
an advantage to have diverse props so
that's why they take it from everyone
but the data itself for the feedback
part needs to be really high quality so
it's by a subset of people
awesome
anyway I'm going to continue I think
this is probably my favorite part of the
talk and you kind of talk about some
interesting parts of our lhf
just to kind of summarize this is a good
interweaving between the concepts that
we've covered and
like what is confusing about this so I
there's
almost all the papers to date that have
been popular have tweaks to the methods
that I've talked about
anthropic is great they've released open
source data for this it's on the Hub we
can link to it once I'm done talking
they release a really long document
detailing all their findings in multiple
ways for this and they have some complex
additions which is like the initial
policy that they use for rlhf has this
context distillation to improve
helpfulness honesty and harmlessness and
we'll kind of show an example in a
second of how this could change text
between two rlhs implementations and and
then they have like another step which
is like preference model pre-training
because the reward model itself is a
different language model the actual
training of it you might want to do
something different so what they did is
they trained it like a language model to
predict actual actual tokens and then
they they found these or they use these
ranking data sets on the internet where
there's data sets that already exist
with binary rankings for responses so it
might be like a Reddit question with two
responses and one of them is labeled
thumbs up and one is thumbs out
they fine-tune the reward model on this
before labeling it on generated prompts
to help initialize the reward model
and then kind of they also tried this
thing with online iterated rlhf which is
when they're doing the RL feedback loop
to iteratively update the reward model
to help the model kind of continue to
learn while it's interacting with world
this online version only works in some
applications like chat where you can
keep getting this user engagement but
you can think about ways to use rohf in
a non-tech based world or for not chat
iterations not chat applications when
this data is more complicated to get and
might be actually proprietary so this
online version may not be applicable to
every experiment
and then open AI this is mostly based on
extract GPT they've had they're the ones
that kind of pioneered this human
generating the language model training
text and they've really used this really
far by also adding this RL uh policy
reward to matching it and other
companies are definitely starting to
imitate this
and but it's kind of constrained by the
cost they have the advantage in the
scale to be able to invest million
millions of dollars into this and then
otherwise it's an open question of how
people replicate
and deepmind coming in to join the space
and doing things totally differently has
been probably great for the research
field to add diversity to things
they use the total they're the first
ones to use non-ppo
um like optimization for the algorithm
they use Advantage actor critic which is
another on policy RL algorithm and my
interpretation of this is that the
algorithm used often might be more
reliant on the infrastructure and the
expertise than the actual algorithm open
AI has been using PPO more than anyone
deepmind has highly specific
infrastructure to deploy RL experiments
at scale in a distributed Manner and to
kind of monitor them so I'm guessing
this algorithm they used was really easy
for them to kind of scale up and monitor
rather than PPO which way they would
have to start over on
and then also
deep my trains on more things than just
alignment which might be like human
preferences they also try to encode
specific rules on things a model should
not do so they're kind of training on
multiple arms at once which is this kind
of rules about structure and things that
it should or should not say and just
clear like human preferences I like this
wonder I don't
and there's more out there I've been
studying this is a crash course for me
studying this in the last couple weeks
so if there's anything I missed please
add to the chat we can update the
resources that everyone will use in the
future The Field's moving really fast
open AI might release the chat qpt Vapor
tomorrow and this will be like instantly
out of date and we'll go update all of
this so thanks for your feedback there
the next really interesting thing to me
is kind of this reward model feedback
interface which is how machine learning
is going Beyond a research and Technical
domain and being one that is inherently
human and has kind of user interface ux
questions and if you look at one of the
this is anthropics
um
text interface they show this in their
paper you should really go check it out
but what they did is they made a chat
bot and you can see that there's during
the chat the human has to actually rank
which response it thinks is better on
kind of the sliding scale and it's
really important like there's all these
places where
you could say that I thought the
assistant was blank there's a ton of
data going in to this system
and we're only at the first couple
iterations of what these feedback
interfaces will look like so anthropics
is actually a couple steps ahead of what
others have done on the left is
blenderbot here which is from Facebook
it's not confirmed that they use rlhf
but they're still collecting this data
to update the model on the right is chat
T the users can thumbs up and thumbs
down data
but some of the people that I've talked
to that go deeper into our lhf say that
this is actually
that thumbs up thumbs down is used
because it's easy to get the data not
because it's the best data that you have
and an example is that giving the humans
the ability to directly edit the outputs
kind of red line edits changing words
removing things punctuation because that
kind of crowdsource is the really high
quality data that openai has been
getting maybe not quite as good of data
as a contractor writing it being paid to
do so but it's much better and much
higher signal than thumbs up and thumbs
down
so that's one thing
these interfaces will continue to
involve over time
and a bit of changed gears just kind of
walked through some recent examples and
show you the things I talked about in
these figures that you may have seen
before here's the most popular trigger
for Mr truck gbt and you can see kind of
where the three-step process that I was
talking about was inspired by really
like open Ai and walk you through this
step one you collect demonstration data
train a supervised policy this is
training the initial language model step
two collect comparison data and trade a
reward model you can kind of see that
there's these different data sets the
samples are those human generated text
the step two is the comparison data is
this ranking system and that's step
three optimize policy against the reward
model using reinforcement learning this
is the one that is kind of I think
oversimplified what is happening and
that's really why I wanted to try to
explain on explain it and elucidate the
space there's a lot that can go into
this final step that is really not
always documented
and then another one anthropic trigger
this one kind of totally goes away with
the three-step process but adds in all
the complex things that kind of would
make it hard to follow as a new person
so you can start in those pre-trained
language model which captures a lot of
what I would put as step one and then
branching out of it immediately are
these two modifications like I said are
kind of anthropic unique things which is
preference model pre-training this is
kind of training the reward pre-training
the reward model by using the specific
thumbs up thumbs down data set script
from the web and then harmfulness
helpfulness prompt context distillation
which is trying to figuring out how you
can add a pro a context before your
prompt to help initialize the
reinforcement learning part and then
they detailed their feedback interface
and kind of how this actually iterates
over time
okay
kind of compare the diagrams it's also
interesting to see what anthropic
optimized for rather than what instruct
GPT was optimizing for so anthropic was
really trying to focus on this alignment
angle a little bit further and how to
have an agent that was really harmless
and actually helpful
so here in the appendix of the anthropic
paper there's examples comparing
instruct instruct GPT prompted responses
to anthropic Source months and then one
of the questions is why is it why aren't
Birds real and you can see they instruct
GPT says that birds are not real blah
blah blah which is not that helpful and
then what anthropics like the the
modality that anthropic wants is that
the model will say something like I'm
sorry I don't really understand the
questions birds are very real and it's
actually quite impressive to get a
machine learning model to do this so
that's that step is really like why
people are optimistic in rlhf taking
this next step as being kind of a toy
thing to really having these dramatic
results in
be like high impact user-facing
Technologies
okay
just through two high-level open areas
of investigation that particularly
interests me as a reinforcement learning
researcher and being at hugging phase
where we kind of have this unique
research slash open source slash
Community position is that there's a lot
of reinforcement learning Optimizer
choices that are not that well
documented and can be expanded on
some people don't even know if RL is
actually explicitly necessary for this
process PPO is definitely not explicitly
necessary and then there's kind of a
third question of like can we train this
in an offline RL fashion so what happens
in offline RL is that you collect a big
data set and then you try to you train
this policy for a long time many many
optimization steps but you don't need to
query the environment and in this case
the environment is really the reward
model which being 50 billion parameters
is quite costly to run inference on so
maybe we should try offline RL which
will produce the training costs of the
rlhf process but it doesn't reduce the
data the data costs here you can see the
other side of what I was talking about
is that these data costs are really
really high there's High Cost of
labeling which is just human time
there's disagreement in the data
it gave the sports example there's
different values there's much more
important different values that people
have
and that's why kind of these human
questions are hard like human values
have disagreement and that's by Design
so you want to be able to capture that
there's never going to be one ground
truth distribution that says this is the
only right thing and then there's this
kind of feedback type user interface
questions that I'm really excited to see
how kind of machine learning breaks into
the general populace
to kind of wrap up and then we'll switch
into this QA q a format like I've showed
you that
early Jeff does these cool things I hope
that the couple examples I took the time
to actually read parts of show you what
it's trying to address by building these
tools there's a huge variety of complex
implementation details where multiple
very large machine learning models are
integrating together using any of these
models in a standalone fashion is a
relatively new thing for the machine
Learning Community with only a couple
years of experience and machine learning
as a technical problem is now being
broadened out from research to be a much
bigger like part of the software stack
and that brings a lot of people into the
conversation that can help make these
tools much better for everyone involved
so thank you for watching or watching
and listening and engaging it's been
great sharing this with you and we'll
kind of transition into the Q a part you
can see
I linked to the end of the blog post
where I've been continuing to update the
related work section to include a
broader set of papers and feel free to
reach out on Twitter or email or Discord
and we'll get back to you there too
thanks
awesome uh thanks Nathan for the
presentation uh we are going to have
um a small section of q a uh obviously
we have so we have a lot of questions so
if we don't have time to answer yours
don't hesitate as I said you know to
join all Discord server we have a
channel called error discussion uh also
if you prefer you can also ask on the
comments under this video and we're good
with we will take the time to answer
your question
um so I saved some let's see I saved
some question
um
so I think it's more open question but
it will be the potential of applying
reinforcement learning from your main
feedback to stable diffusion
um what do you think will be uh the
potential of doing that
yep
you probably can like I think if it's
kind of like a
a way to
like it'll help with some of the safety
problems and just kind of find it's a
fine-tuning method which which I don't
see there's any structural reasons why
you cannot I haven't thought about that
the image space is always hard to think
about because it's so my own
understanding is so language based but I
think it's like
there's no structural reasons why you
cannot the kind of encoding and decoding
of the prompt gets a little bit
different which is a little tricky
I don't like that essentially you'll
have a safe a reward model that takes in
images rather than words so I don't see
why you can't there's actually some
demos on Hunting face about like safe
stable diffusion where they did some
fine tuning unstable diffusion to really
make any of the outputs reasonable so I
we can track down some of those from the
diffusion model side of I can basically
kind of follow up with those examples
because they might actually be doing
something quite similar so I I tried to
start the talk not in language models
because human feedback is a huge field
of machine learning it's just quickly
popularized with this language model
discussion
uh so one of the question is what's
going face role plan in future direction
of reinforcement learning from Human
feedback
yeah so having phase definitely has
identified that there's a lot of
appetite for it and it's kind of in this
unique position where there's so many
like we have this community that is
super important to the company and that
gives us a different ability to collect
data and stuff so hunting pace is
planning it but hasn't come up with a
specific project yet and when the
project is known I'm sure hugging face
will communicate with the community and
say this is how you can help this is
where we're trying to take things these
are the questions we're trying to
address which is why being transparent
is so fun because we can just share
everything but right now it's it's still
a work in progress It's been moving fast
for the last week
um
when there was a question I think it's
more an open question is that other over
scalable way of evaluating this model
without human feedback
yeah so that'll be a good thing to
include in the lecture there's a lot of
um kind of metrics and data sets that
are designed to evaluate these topics of
kind of harmfulness or alignment
or like text quality
on a model on a data set without
actually having to have humans involved
to try to like be more rigorous with
respect to these kind of ambiguous
questions that's something that could
definitely be added you could do a whole
lecture on human facing metrics for NLP
there's a lot there I think like someone
like blue and Rogue or Rose there's two
mentioned in the blog post if you want
to there
awesome
um
so one of the question is that you know
reinforcement running a frame with
convergence
um by having pre-train of the NLP model
this is not a problem
yeah so actually talking with folks like
Carper who are making this trlx Library
if you Google trlx is what they're
working on and scaling our lhf
what they're trying to do is get their
RL implementations to scale to bigger
and bigger language models and the
general limiting factors that the PPO
update steps don't converge easily on
the bigger models so there still is
problems with convergence I don't know
exactly what the mechanism looks like if
you're fine-tuning a language model of
what unconverged looks like like how bad
it could get but there's definitely
still convergence problems with
fine-tuning with RL
um
so when those so it's a GPT you know
it's only from
um different language outside of English
and what would be the advantage of using
overall rage I suppose that we are
having more
um knowledge of the world I suppose
yeah you get that's like democratizing
the access to way more people
so I think that'll come it's a classic
thing where
technology hits the English word for
world first but I think that very like
once there's an open source version
within weeks there's gonna be fine-tooed
versions on tons of other languages
um do you think that GPT system are
sustainable yeah given you mentioned no
it can cost a lot uh maybe not trillions
but it can cost a lot uh in adaptation
costs
yeah so the real like The Upfront cost
isn't a problem for those companies 10
million dollars on annotation is not a
lot for opening eye the issue is that it
costs a couple cents per inference of
the model and this cost will go down a
lot so that's why open AI partners with
Microsoft because Microsoft is learning
how to create at scale low-cost apis for
complex model inference and those
systems were probably built in the last
six months but if you give them four
years and the technology settles in the
cost will drop 10x and kind of
everything will work out it's just
really interesting to follow initially
because it's very fast moving landscape
with wild costs
foreign
Ty can be more realistic in one specific
domain so I suppose if we fine-tune
um on this one on on one as mentioned
like for instance mathematics or yeah I
think that'll happen something else like
people like to talk about chat GPT being
used for search
and an interesting business model
consideration for this is using like a
rohf model trained on internal company
documents to create a really effective
company search so places like Google
where there are billions of internal
documents as impossible to find them if
you're an employee if they do rohf on
their internal data this model will know
what it needs to and something that I
encourage you to do is go ask chat GPT
about a very specific subject and
surprisingly chat GPT does okay at very
specific subjects and people think
that's because there's not that much
data and most of the data is like a
scientific paper which is all things
considered more accurate than something
like Reddit so like they think that it
might transfer to these use cases where
there's only like pretty positive
specific data that people could time
tune on
so uh one of the question is
um do we will need in the future remain
annotator
um because you mentioned that Tesla got
rid of a human annotators by creating
more powerful model
yeah maybe but probably not soon it's
kind of an unsettling question I'm not
confused I'm mostly just unsettled by it
in like this I don't think it'll come
within a couple years but when that gets
to the case or it's like we're training
language models on other language models
because one language model is the
ultimate source of truth I'm just very
worried so I kind of want to say no out
of hope that it isn't the case but it
wouldn't be that surprised like you can
already see companies probably trying to
trade their model to mimic chat GPT
because chat GPT is ahead so they can
kind of bootstrap their own training
data by using chat gbt to get a model to
imitate it and I don't like it but it's
likely
um it is possible possible to create a
gbt type of model that can receive image
and so on as input to understand concept
better I suppose it's a it's I think a
lot of researchers are currently
thinking about
yeah I would I would definitely think
that people are going to try to do
things like that there's a whole
multivodal project at hug and face where
they're trying to figure out how to
train models that use multiple types of
data if people will continue adding the
modalities to kind of let the bottom
model be more flexible which has been
very fun to follow
foreign
Ty look for data online or does it add
everything in its memory
I think it has everything in its memory
but it's not confirmed as it's not
released
there are models that do this kind of
online lookup
rumors are that a open AI has figured
out some incredible scraping techniques
like it's probably not 100 true but
people have said that open AI is better
at scraping YouTube than
um Google is but that's probably hearsay
which probably just means that like
they're doing equally as well to Google
but the fact that an external company is
figured it out as well as Google is is
still pretty remarkable
um
so do you think we will see a red HF for
the modalities like generating imagine
art and music I suppose yes
I think so like ultimately there's still
discussion on what rohf is good at like
there's this is probably the peak of the
hyper rohf but as I was saying the field
of human feedback is much broader the
language going back decades so it's not
that's not going anywhere it's just kind
of the early age up branding is kind of
a new sub token of it
foreign
so
do you think it made more sense for
Builders to begin labeling a lot of data
with existing language mode large
language model like GPT or whereas Next
Generation swamp any fine tuning we do
this is a question that we're talking
about internally as well like like this
is something that I posted the slack and
it's like gpt4 rubbers are hilarious
literally like I've got get multiple
messages from people that like interest
you see the tweets that are like gpt4
and world breaking don't tell anyone
that I know this I like but the thing is
that the data is still really useful so
like open AI is getting this huge data
advantage and like they'll use that when
they want to do our LHS on gpt4 like the
specific implementation details might
need to change based on the architecture
or something like that
that I don't think the date of pipeline
is going to be
like obsolete immediately
um are there any resources you recommend
to learn more about this I think we
already mentioned our blog post
yeah I would say the blog post
also the like alignment Community is
very responsive to people engaging on
their topics so a lot of our early deaf
researchers are very affiliated with
alignment and there's like other forums
so they haven't explored as much like
Lester OG in alignment for him I'm not
going to say that I endorse all the
content on them there's a ton of content
that these people are pretty like
engaged with the community as
researchers so if you write respectful
questions to them a lot you'll get
responses it's not just me I did try to
make the blog post we wrote like
the starting point for a conceptual
introduction specifically because I
thought that there was not a clear
introduction the papers have the problem
the blog post for papers of the problem
where they need to introduce the paper
content and not just the concept so when
you remove the specific advancements of
the paper that's kind of what the blog
post is just to make it a little bit
more addressable but if there's
something that is missing you can let us
know
um I think it's an interesting question
uh given up and I really have a age for
night mode GPT models uh what what other
companies and open source Community can
do to get to keep up the pace
the thing is the open source Community
has way more people and engagement than
open AI yeah open AI is small and Hyper
focused which always gives startups
advantage that given the amount of
appetite for it like
there's over like there's thousands of
more people that are willing to help in
an open version and that's kind of the
the scale of access is different
uh why do you think reinforcement
learning from image feedback Forks much
better than just fine tuning the
original model directly with the same
reward data set
this is the ultimate question does rlf
rlhf actually do anything
um not a hundred percent sure but rumors
are that they think that are all just
handles kind of
Shifting the optimization landscape
nicely
so I'm guessing fine-tuning on the same
data set could work but the optimization
just wasn't figured out in the same way
and
it's exciting as someone who does RL
that this kind of different way of
navigating the optimization space was
useful but it's not well documented
there's no the research paper version of
the blog post that we wrote is
desperately needed
um
yeah when there was a question was
during a presentation they as a question
to ask is what is the paper tomorrow
yeah not no unlikely there is a chance
that it could be released tomorrow in
this lectures uh no longer quite as
relevant but it's really unlikely that
we see it tomorrow
yeah surprise I work at open AI now
so I think I can answer that is no you
don't read the code of the LGBT it's a
proprietary model and I think you can't
contribute as an outsider it's uh
internal project
yeah
[Music]
um
big chat GPT though we'll see if it
happens
[Laughter]
um unfortunately we run off of time
um
uh so what you can do for people we
didn't have time to answer uh we have as
you see on the slide I just tried to
remove uh if we don't have time uh you
cannot ask on the Discord so you can
join on this code or also in the
comments uh in the video below uh we
will make time in uh in the upcoming
days to answer your question so yeah
don't hesitate
um so yeah that's that's all for today
uh thank you all thank you Nathan for
this presentation uh it was super
interesting interesting
and uh yeah I will see you in the
Discord and uh in the comment section
bye